to the business and I decided that
product was the area that interested me
most but I didn't feel like I had the
technical chops specifically with
regards to pulling my own data from a
database manipulating that data in Excel
to pull insights and then using some
sort of data visualization tool like
tableau to bring those insights
powerfully to my audience in a
compelling way and so I didn't quite
have what I needed to make that change
or to try and break into that industry
until I found Udacity nanodegree program
and the business analytics program that
I went through taught me exactly those
things I learned sequel to pull my own
data
I learned Excel in depth formulas so I
can manipulate that data to find
powerful insights and then I learned
tableau so that I could put those
insights into a visual form and make
them more compelling and powerful for my
audience because of that I was given a
trial to join the product team I
performed well throughout that trial
because of the preparation of the
nanodegree and then I was granted a
position on the product team after that
just where I am today right fate so I
think that's also very inspiring
considering starting from customer
service now as a project manager I think
it's a I think because of that
experience Alex Bob you have been able
to change to something product which is
eventually he's learning about the
customers so yeah that's really great
and I'm sure a lot of us will think
would have something about what project
manager does because they must have been
interacting with them a lot all right
thanks again thanks again everyone thank
you so much for sharing your wonderful
stories a new experience and I just
can't you know I'm just more excited to
ask you more questions on behalf of all
the participants that we have right so
you know without any further ado I
actually have one the one question so I
think some of so all of you have done
actually briefly talk about it but if
you could talk more about it I think
mega you know started first about you
know learning about digital marketing
but yeah if you could more about you
know what was your reason from a
professional point of view for picking
the nanodegree digital marketing what
was your reason behind it
so when I first started with my job
hunting phrases ever I have got offered
the job who's that you don't worry
general but if I'm not ready you might
mean that I will passionate about so
when I started applying for jobs what
moose were looking into if you have
experience in some kale life projects or
not so that was freaky in that time I
realized that whatever courses I were
taking back then like the fetuses with
not meeting my giving like job ready so
that's why I took nano degree because
you know each and every module is
supplemented by a real-life project so I
working when I start working on them and
yeah at the end of the degree I had a
lot of project and then people increased
that since I have done so many projects
I am the right rate so great thanks so
much
Celeste would you like to talk about
your reason from you know going into
business analytics neurotically
considering even to customer service now
your project manager so I think you you
don't want to do something but I think
if you could share your reason for
choosing it that will be really really
helpful
sure so it's worth stating that the
company I joined you to start up and the
reason that's worth stating is that it
means that everyone here has like ten
jobs that they do and that's very true
for the product people in specific they
we didn't have at the time data analysts
we didn't have you know business
intelligence teams to pull this data and
manipulate it for us and so if you
wanted to drive in insights you needed
data to do that and we only had
ourselves to pull it only I didn't know
sequel and I didn't know how to how to
move that data and do anything we didn't
pull anything out of it I was at the
point where I would if I needed to get
to the bottom of a spreadsheet from the
top I would click down each cell all the
way to get to the bottom okay that's not
how you're supposed to do it just so you
know there's a shortcut
I didn't know that at the time and so I
wanted to fill that gap and make myself
marketable for the position that I
wanted because I saw that with the
startup there's always a lot of lateral
flexibility and there's a lot of
opportunity to grow into new teams so I
wanted to jump on that wave but I needed
the skills to get there
luckily my company actually offers a
professional development budget and so I
was able to use that to get my managers
approval and get this Udacity nanodegree
program rolling Business Analytics was a
natural fit because it was exactly what
I wanted to do it I already had a base
of sequel but I wanted to get better at
it and it helped me do that I already
had a basics of Excel and sheet
manipulation but I wanted to get better
at it and it showed me how to do that
and similarly with tableau I had only
had a very very shallow introduction and
it really gave me the deep dive and help
me feel like I was in control of my own
data and therefore here in this company
one of my own destiny yeah I still you
know to date I still like cell and
although I you know pick up some tricks
to do it and I luckily for me I don't
need to really press every time to go to
that you know particular cell but yeah I
think I've been you know I've been in
that place I can certainly say that very
coming from indefinitely its must have
been really good to learn all those
things and definitely being a project -
again it's a big achievement thanks
thanks so much right Edward I mean you
have done a lot of nanodegrees what was
your reason for going from one
nanodegree to another neither degrees so
what was your thought behind that
professionally sure when I first started
taking 9a degrees machine learning and
data analysts were the only two that
were available within data science but
as the breadth of Nan agrees broadened
and more became available I decided to
focus a little bit more some of them
were job related I took the react nano
degree because that helped me find new
contracts as a web developer the other
nanodegrees were a little bit more based
on my own interest and things that I've
been reading so a lot of the material in
the AI nano degree follow
material in the artificial intelligence
of modern approach which is the text
book by Peter Norvig and more recently
the deep learning and natural processing
nanodegrees specifically related my
spirit AI the work that I do on the
Allied product which has to do with the
classification of toxic behavior and
game communities uses natural language
processing and natural language
understanding to a large extent and even
though I don't necessarily write a lot
of that code it does help knowing what
other data scientists are working on
that's sort of how I chose that that
path to answer your question from
earlier about how did I manage attacking
and addressing so many the pattern that
I followed is that even though the the
course schedule is laid out in a linear
process which has a certain narrative I
did jump around and found that some
material in a different order worked for
how I was learning it I also would look
at projects before I started the
material so that way I understood what
the project was trying to tackle as I
was going through the material I would
be doing the project in parallel rather
than right at the end and I found that
was a good workflow to work through the
nanodegrees relatively quickly great
great yeah I think you know in those
experience specifically in AI yeah is
always a token town and combining this
will help develop an experiences itself
is very nation so you know it's really
again inspiring to hear that besides
just doing web development which itself
is a very big domain to begin with you
have more going in-depth with the data
science and artificial intelligence so
guys I'm sure there'll be a lot of
questions post this event just to talk
about AI or nanoscience particularly so
just be ready for those questions all
right okay thanks again everyone okay so
I think one of the question that is very
common and which is already there and I
also wanted to talk to you about this
you know what are the things that you
really find impactful you know that
actually help you in finding your you
know your career path because earlier
you were doing
different stuff now you and they
different stuff I think you briefly
talked about in an interview stuff but
what one thing that really stood out you
know which actually helps you to find
your career path in the current role
that you're in can I take this one
yeah DISA nice quiet okay
so I don't know if anyone ever had that
science professor who wanted to teach
you about specificity and they use this
peanut butter and jelly sandwich as an
example okay and they just thing where
they've got like a bag of bread and
they've got a jar of jelly and they've
got a jar of peanut butter and then they
ask the class tell me how to make a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich and the
class will say well you just put jelly
and peanut butter on the bread and then
you eat it and so the teacher takes the
jar of jelly in the jar of peanut butter
and places them on top of the bag of
bread and tries to pick up the whole
thing and pretend to take a bite and the
students all laugh and it's quite funny
because the idea is that you're supposed
to say take this layer you know open the
bag of bread reach into the bag of bread
grab the slice of bread pull out the
slice of bread you can go so in depth
with it I love that kind of stuff that
is my bread and butter forgive the pun
but I you know didn't know that you
could make a career out of it that is
apparently a lot of what product does
and I only learned that because I had
the opportunity to talk to product
people and you know I was I was as I
said a customer support person but there
was a product person that I really
admired and I just asked them hey can we
grab coffee
you know once a week and chat about your
experience on the product team and he
said yeah absolutely which is very kind
of him and he won't always get that
lucky and that's okay and you just keep
asking folks and we went and had weekly
coffees and he told me about product and
I asked all these questions and it
turned out you get to figure out how
stuff is built and why people want stuff
and who thinks what and how you can
satisfy all their needs and it's just so
it's so intellectually stimulating I
really love it so that's that's what I
found about product that I knew I I
really loved was how the how the details
really
on something okay yeah please go ahead
yeah sure
and this actually touches upon one of
the questions that are at that's in the
chat the transition from web development
to AI really concerned me I didn't think
that I'd be able to compete at a similar
level of seniority and a company that
I've built up as a web developer and I
didn't want to go back to being a junior
engineer in an AI field so I was trying
to figure out how do I negotiate that
process and I found that a really good
way to do that is to take a job in a
company that does the domain work that
you want to do but leveraging the
experience that you have so I took a job
as a senior engineer working on the
stream processing platform at spirit AI
and at a start-up there are more
problems to solve than people to solve
them and nobody's going to be annoyed
with you for taking responsibility to
solve problems that need solving
so I transitioned from web development
and doing more software engineering into
AI engineering by simply helping solve
the problems that needed solving in that
area and it didn't actually take that
long for that work to be recognized and
for the company to turn around and
effectively redefine my role around that
work that's I think particularly true in
startups where the idea of a role is
very fluent Celeste was talking about
this everybody is doing multiple jobs
which means that there's a lot of
opportunity for career progression and
transitioning between roles and it's
really up to you to try and take
advantage of those opportunities when
you're in a space like that thanks
thanks for sharing that right Megha I
think you've already talked about you
know a lot about this but yeah if you
could just brief more than be made yeah
like you asked what was the most
impactful thing that you know made me
choose this career so like you know a
traditional marketing
is getting old and old and it is less
targeted like the billboards there you
know there it is very difficult to
measure like how many people actually
saw your ad and the ones I heard talk in
my family but you know the future of
traditional marketing is nowhere and you
have to get into digital marketing
because you know technology is advancing
so that day I realized that to keep pace
with this generation I have to get into
digital marketing so I think that was
the thing that made an impact in my life
and I made a decision that this is what
I would do for the rest of my life hey
thanks thanks so much for saying I know
that's you know part from the good stuff
let's talk about the challenges so what
were the biggest challenges you know you
experienced when applying to the jobs
related to your nd and how did you
overcome those challenges please make a
boy yes so you know after completing my
nano degree when I first started
applying for jobs and lot of people were
asking me like what you have done in
this field can you please show your
projects so it became very difficult for
me to sing the link of the projects so
what I did was I to solve this problem I
created a website and there I put all my
digital marketing projects and next I'm
like whenever I'm applying for jobs I
started giving them the link to my
website so that was one of the best
thing that I ever done Oh like mija
asked in a question not how she should
search my job because she is unemployed
as she mentioned so I think you should
create a website and put all your
projects and just you know tell people
that what you have done and showcase
your projects as a backup and you very
definitely get high if people are
impressed by your projects and yeah in
you know mind nanodegree a student of
the month quiz was organized for every
week so I used to create presentations
for the same so you know it a city did
helped me to improve my presentation
skills and if you
I can show you my projects like I used
to create presentations for all the
projects so yeah it did help me
hey thanks Megha I think it'll be really
helpful if you could you know just post
a link of the website that you just
mentioned there on my LinkedIn profile
under portfolio so we can connect short
so we'll take your LinkedIn profiles at
the end and if you wish to connect with
the students they will reach out you
would land in so that we really create
okay
thanks thanks so much for that major
right I'll talk about a challenge with
the transition process or interview job
getting process yeah but it's it's
pretty hard to convince someone that you
are correct when you say I know what I'm
doing especially when it comes to data
and in software startups it's all if you
can't back it up with data and nobody
wants to listen to you which can be seen
as a shortcoming for sure and you need
to bring the human into things but I
walked in there saying I think I can do
great with data and they said oh yeah
prove it and so similar to Megha I
actually used my Udacity projects I
pulled out the things that I had done
and made in my nano degree and I said
look I made this profit and loss
statement look I made this dashboard
look I need these things myself you know
I do know what I'm doing I do know how
to find the answers even if I don't have
the answers already and I think that
that was a really powerful leg up in
that process and really made me seem
very put together and very professional
to overcome that challenge that's that's
yeah I think up you know we have always
been you know very positive about the
fact that these products are really
helpful and it's just not about
completing those projects about how you
label to explain it to to the employers
happen to the interviewers we're asking
about it so I think that's the you know
it's a key takeaway from those
experiences and so that's one of the one
of the guys say that one of the members
in the you know parts
member says if they were like to connect
with you over an opportunity in
excellence would that be impossible or
not so we will talk about it at the end
of the event but yeah this is something
that you know I should want to bring it
up for you this we're hiring just FYI
it's good news
thanks thanks so much the nice for that
all right Edward it's your turn oh sure
and it follows a similar theme in
engineering roles github plays an
absolutely massive part of the hiring
process it's where you can demonstrate
your work it's where you can demonstrate
your personal projects and nasty
projects you can put into github
projects and whether you build a website
around it that might be suitable for for
certain projects but as long as you
demonstrate an interest and you
demonstrate an ability to to
problem-solve in that domain employers
don't really care whether it's work that
you've done for a company or it's paid
work or it's something that you've done
on your own and in fact demonstrating
that you can drive yourself to to learn
something you and your own time and
build projects in your own time and your
self-directed and you're interested in
continuous education is a massive
benefit it's it's çetin it's absolutely
critical because everybody's expecting
you to continue learning while you're in
the job and the job is going to change
while you're you're working in it so
showing that you're you're able to
demonstrate that abilities is massive
I just want to pile on to that and say
what what Edward just said is critically
important the fact that you are out
there pursuing education on your own
time and learning because you want to
and you think it's the right choice for
yourself that's what differentiates you
that's why you are the right fit the
right candidate the right new hire you
know and showcasing that is actually I
think Chad Burt's point point more
important than the actual final product
of a produced well that matters it's the
fact you went out there to do it
so really lean on that and say look I I
am a learner I am a grower I seek out
opportunities to improve myself and and
myself as an employee
so just worth piling onto that yeah
thanks thanks so it's lists for you know
adding that on the top of what already
been I'm going to discuss a good Edward
then I think here definitely it shows
that kind of when you highlight those
projects during the interview it's it
makes the person more interesting nobody
just looking for a yes-or-no answer
saying do you have experience yes so you
should say what kind of experience do
you have strengths yeah three know who
you should tell I can a strengths that
you have how did you get those kind of
strengths so that's pretty helpful buddy
I think there's another prominent
question I wanted to ask you that okay
so when you were there in the interview
we got the idea but what before the
interview you know when lot of times
students don't even get shortlisted
their resume don't get through our to
the you know to the interview phase so
you know maybe if you could share about
something the strategies that you tried
applying you know the jobs and that's
really help you with getting into a
invitation to the interview
sure I can talk about that when you're
first starting out it's really hard and
it is a numbers game when I applied for
when I actually got my first engineering
job I applied to a hundred companies and
was offered one interview and was lucky
enough to actually get a job at that
company but once you get a little bit of
experience you're able to move her a lot
more easily in the workplace you can try
and get experience that is maybe
tangential to what you're currently
doing at work but it's closer to what
you want to be achieving and then you
use that as a stepping stone once you
have a little bit of experience in one
job you tend to be a lot more marketable
and then you can be a little bit more
selective and maybe this is an approach
that is maybe very commonly discussed
but it applies to transitioning careers
as well that maybe be a little less
selective for the first job or the first
opportunity but if there's a way for you
to leverage that and get closer to where
you want to go then I see that as being
a good way forward and is often a more
productive approach than spending a lot
of time looking for the perfect job and
not necessarily getting the experience
that could help you get there along the
way can I jump in yeah please
I understand the perspective of playing
a numbers game and that in some
industries that may be what it requires
my own experience differs from that a
bit I found that the more successful way
to get an invitation to an interview is
through networking I tried the numbers
game and for the types of roles that I
was interested in it didn't work
you know I threw my resume down so many
black holes that I doubt anyone ever
looked at and applying through LinkedIn
and applying through Glassdoor or
jobless com
whatever these these platforms are no
one's really looking at those honestly
the way the people get jobs in the
industry that I'm in right
today in the area that I'm in this may
not be true for you but it's good for me
is by knowing people who know people and
figuring out who you know who knows
someone and you can do that through
Facebook you can do that through
LinkedIn you can do that through the
people that you talk to every day you
know hey do you know anyone who works at
X company and so for me it is about
finding a company I want to work at
seeing if I know anyone who knows anyone
there and whether I can work my way in
towards it and maybe if I really can't
there's no fourth step connection that I
can talk to that I might change which
company I'm looking at and try a
different inroad I might even be
exploring multiple at the same time but
for me it's about getting someone who is
near someone else to get a coffee with
you
to send your resume to their colleague
who's one step closer to a hiring
manager to send it to their hiring
manager who's actually in charge of the
role and I've actually found that to be
much more successful for me personally
hands big technical experience then
playing a numbers game on this
particular one so I would say if you
know anyone who is in the sector that
you want to be in regardless of what
company there at talk to them figure out
who they know find them on LinkedIn find
them on Facebook look at who they know
who might be somewhere near the company
or companies that you're interested in
and just try and get a copy with them
see if it is a good fit great yeah
thanks and I think you know we do have
you know we wanted to actually talk
about networking but that's great that
you really brought that up I think we
certainly take that in the next portion
and I'm actually going to ask about this
in details about you know the networking
platform that you mentioned but yeah
since I think Celeste you mentioned that
you also have been interviewing a lot of
guys you know for maybe for your team or
you may have been part of the you know
hiring process also so I definitely take
those things in account that networking
is very important but once a candidate
is there what do you see in that
candidate would sit he's saying before
you and he's just presenting and resume
from from an interviewer perspective
what are the things that you would
really keen to look at in the person
definitely and yes I have been doing a
lot of interviewing lately yesterday I
think I saw four candidates
and that's eat up almost my entire day
it's been in case just for context here
our company just got a 250 million
dollar funding round and we're now a
unicorn and so all of a sudden we have a
whole lot of candidates for all these
open positions that we have go figure so
we're doing a lot of interviewing we are
trying to hire and scale quickly and so
I've become one of our interviewers
which given how recently I joined the
product team which was earlier this year
it's really exciting and awesome that I
get to participate in that interviewing
and hiring process and one of the things
that it has taught me is what to look
for when I am going into an interview
and so as I'm interviewer I'm learning a
lot of how to be an interviewee which is
fantastic so some of the things that I'm
looking for right off the bat I want
someone to look me in the eye and give
me a handshake you know I obviously I
want you to be confident in why you're
here and that you're the right candidate
for the job I ask people obviously I
read their resume and their breakdown of
their career history and I know what I
find interesting but I tell them what do
you find most fascinating about your
career
give me the highlight that you think is
most interesting so that tells me a lot
about folks prepare for some
introspective questions like that things
about why you're here why are you in
this industry you know why are you doing
what you do so prepare some answers for
that specifically for product we run
cases we do case based interviews and so
it can be a case about product design it
can be a case about go to market
strategy it can be a case about product
market fit there's all kinds of things
that that it could be about so I would
say depending on which area of the
business you're looking at are you on
the growth side are you on the servicing
existing customers side and then
understand what the area is that they're
gonna ask you about because if it's a
growth question they might say imagine
that you are you know the CEO of this
company and you decide to launch this
new product what would you do to tell
the public about it and get it off the
ground you know and that's pretty
open-ended so what I'm looking for for a
question like that is structure I want
you to zoom out and say okay well what
is the company goal what are we trying
to achieve here okay great base
what metric are we trying to move okay
great based on that what are the users
who are the users what do they want what
are their needs where are the gaps today
okay based on that here's how I would
talk to them about it and so then you ID
and then you bring solutions and then
you prioritize those solutions based on
the impact they might have so really I'm
just looking for that structure I don't
need you to tell me yes or no we're
gonna launch this thing I need you to
tell me how you would get to a yes or a
No and that's gonna be true on the
growth on the servicing on every single
side of product it's actually very
similar to data analyst roles as well
because the interviews will be a lot
more technical there'll be a lot more
numbers base but they'll also have a lot
of business thinking they'll ask about
main business metrics like CAC customer
acquisition cost or LTV lifetime value
these are things you'll learn in the
nanodegree program these are things that
you can learn in in the workplace as
well but you know if you want a quick
boost to get there I would take the
nanodegree program to learn about them
you know you learn about return on
investment and you're gonna need to be
able to speak to that if you're
interviewing as a business analyst
specifically so these are some of the
things that I'm looking for is structure
critical thinking and the ability to
think strategically from a high level
even if you are kind of thrown in at the
weeds I want you to zoom out so that's
kind of what we're looking for great
yeah I think that's really helpful and
it's very detailed and I think what you
said you know specifically for the guys
rather than School of Business they
would definitely be very keen to know
that kind of stuff which they never get
to know because most times interviews
don't give them a feedback they say hey
you know we'll get back to you there's a
stable answer then everyone gets but I
think it's one of the most detailed you
know thought you know legal stuff that
ever got to know from someone who's
already a part of the interview process
so that's that's super helpful all right
so I'll actually going to ask about the
networking but I want to ask Meg about
her experience of the challenges that
she faced you know in finding the jobs
related to our nano degree if she said
and how did she overcome those I know
about your experience but is great to
share with everybody
so yeah so our first row Farina I would
like to say that I agree with Celeste
and Edward like networking does help a
lot like the first job that I'm here
like I found it finding been so you know
I have searching for jobs for like three
months but I was unable to find any job
so my brother suggested me that you know
more than 50% of the jobs they're not
even listed online like you get those
jobs through networking so within a
month I sent around 500 connection
requests on LinkedIn I know it's very
spammy but yeah I did connect with a lot
of people within a month and I told them
that I am looking for a digital
marketing job if you know any job or if
you know someone who is hiding just let
me know and you won't believe like out
of 100 people who you receive at least
immediately recognized because most of
the people on LinkedIn they are very
helpful they are like it's time to give
back to the community so I even got in
touch with my mentor and she wrote me a
message that Tim you know throughout my
life a lot of people have helped me so
now it's time to give back to the
community I would help you in every
possible way so I reached out to one of
my thing and she was looking for a
digital marketer and did I got my first
job so that's how networking helps you
so
I could don't same connection request to
send them with a note like what exactly
you want from them otherwise it looks
like I mean oh yeah like my personal
advice like do sing them and would like
how do you them but exactly one from
them and just you know introduce
yourself it helps a lot
great thanks thanks over me yeah I may
go on this and I was actually about to
ask this like ok so we talk about
networking yeah I mean whence we get
into that kind of panic mode hey we want
to you know we really want to get the
job we want to take all those desperate
actions to reach to the people we
definitely would reach out to the you
know the friends to friends of the
friends this to get that kind of
opportunity but I think maybe if you
could share more what do you think now
is the best effective strategy to get
the networking and what should a person
do do more to effectively network so
that he or she would able to see some
results from it I think you already
mentioned and make up maybe others can
tell yeah I think yeah talking to - what
mega was getting at I think it's very
important both to say what it is that
you're looking for when you're
networking but it goes two ways if
you're during the networking process
able to find out what the person you're
you're talking to is looking for as well
that can help and then you can naturally
build up relationships with people
through the networking process and it's
it's not just about getting referrals or
finding out whether a company might be a
suitable fit but once you expand your
network it's really hard to guess what
sort of opportunities might come about
and you know something might come along
that really surprise is
one thing I would add too is that
networking can also be used for
development purposes an example is I had
a friend who worked at Google and I
wasn't applying to Google you know I had
no interest in trying to get a referral
a connection there but I did have them
look over my resume and I asked them to
give me some feedback you know on
whether it was in the right tone and
whether I was saying some of the key
things that would need to leap off the
page at least in the tech sector because
they were in the sector that I was
interested in even though not the
company and so I had someone run
interviews with me a different friend
sat and ran interviews with me and there
was someone who did hiring for their
company and they kind of knew what they
were talking about
there's also digital platforms that'll
pair you with a mock interviewer to work
with each other if you don't have
someone at home to work with but you can
leverage your network to find people who
are doing well
from your perspective of what well means
to you and then talk to them how did
they get there what did they do can they
look over your resume can they look over
your cover letter you know it doesn't
have to be that they are the person
that's gonna get you that job but they
can be the person that tells you how
they got where they are and gives you
kind of a blueprint to follow so that's
worth mentioning as well great yeah I
think yeah it's pretty valuable and we
already have you know the main kind of
resume reviews and cover letter
interviews in career portal so I
actually want to talk about this so you
know I think we believe that courier
services on I mean the term resume and
the cover letter is a valuable way to
get the advice and you know polishing
those documents so do you have any
advice on how to make the most of those
resources as in in the review services
that in the portal it's very useful to
get a review of your interior if you
think that your github profile or your
LinkedIn is already polished it's it's
really helpful just to get somebody else
to look at it who might have a different
perspective depending on where you are
in your job search you might need a
little bit more so
from those career services but all I
touching on that but also what Celeste
was talking about in terms of reaching
out to your network the idea of an
informational interview is very very
important it can give you all sorts of
insight into how people operate in the
industry that you want to move into or
the company that you move into and
simply offering to buy somebody a coffee
and in return for 15 minutes of their
time it can be a big help in terms of
getting yourself out there and also it
helps build up confidence I remember
when I first started networking it was
my least favorite part of the job search
I'm not really a people person and it's
something that took a lot of actives in
order to build up the confidence to
simply start talking to people
especially in a situation where you feel
like you have to sell yourself and you
know it's imposter syndrome is another
big part of it no matter how good you
are you're always going to feel like the
people around you know more than you do
and that's been the case and every job
I've started it happens in interviews
whether I'm the interviewer or the
interviewee and often the case that's
not necessarily a problem people know
different things and there's whether you
have experience in the industry or not
there's something that you can bring to
the table that is going to be of value
to the team that you could be working on
great great I think if you could share
about your experience what are the ways
that it's really you know the people can
effectively use it now
so the basic profile I like it like so
many things so when I submitted my
profile but you know doing a lot of
things like there was a checklist so the
first amazing thing was they would need
they you know made me write long story
in the description so I wrote a story so
when I applied for
job the first thing my recruiter told me
that your story on LinkedIn was amazing
so I think it helped me to actually
start a conversation so it is the first
thing name another thing is the idea I
didn't have much projects listed on
LinkedIn now I have like four or five of
them
another thing is I also attached my
resume and early it was also the basic
one and I designed it because I saw like
you know in the checklist there were a
lot of things I didn't mention in here
so yeah it was of great like from a
basic thing to a professional thing
career services did help me a lot
yes Sam actually I thought I was doing
pretty well on my resume and so I sent
it in and got the the feedback well no
actually until I looked at the checklist
and realized there's a lot that I was
missing but it was really helpful to me
to have a template to have a blueprint
of here are the sections here is how you
approach them here's what you should
have on there both for LinkedIn and for
for the resume and actually I took lots
of screenshots and copy pasted lots of
things to store away forever
the reference always but the the
LinkedIn particularly I was like oh yeah
I'm so strong on LinkedIn recruiters
reach out to me it's all all gravy and
then I realized I didn't have any
projects I realized actually that I had
no idea how to handle my privacy
settings I didn't know what was public
and what was private and because of this
review I had to go in there and go oh I
can actually select individual things
whether I want them to be shown or not
shown to the public which I had no idea
about so I was really at a basic basic
level which I did not even realize until
you'd actually showed me what it would
look like to level up and help me do
that kraid yeah and I can also tell from
my experience you always you know we all
have been there I mean I also struggle a
lot with my LinkedIn profile so yeah and
definitely I think all those valid
points actually you know talk about it's
just not about the reviews I think the
way that you abused the entire ecosystem
of career services starting with a
Linden guitar you know services then
interacting the community I think a lot
of I think we shouldn't I think my
approach would say a definitely LinkedIn
is a biggest platform but I think the
bigger than that I feel currently you
should be part of the comedy that we're
learning we all alone as we all walking
on the same path although our you know
maybe the destination is different but
we all all walk in the same line so I
think the best way is first connect in
the community because there would be
some people who may be just learning new
stuff but they may have an you know a
job opening in their company and they're
looking for some talented people like
you who already want to do something in
their life and they already on a path of
self learning so yeah that's one way of
looking at the
so guys I actually wanted to ask you a
lot of questions but I think we just ran
out of time
from my end to you know ask you those
questions let's you know give this
opportunity now to the students they
have written a lot of questions so I'll
you know take my time one by one going
through and ask you the question some
directly would be let's just say pointed
to just one person it just be general in
pub you know its general to everybody so
I'll do my best to accommodate all those
questions as much as I can
well yeah so let's begin with that
section and thanks again guys for that
you know it was really helpful I can say
that you know each one of the partners
would be really helpful and you know
they'll be you know I'm sure they'll be
really looking forward to have more
events like this all right so now I'm
talking about the questions there in the
chat let me just take that through real
quick okay so there was actually one
question okay let me start first with
this is from push on well do Edward so
add up you know he's actually he says
okay just a feedback he says the
character engine seems really great on
the website on spirit AI you want su you
know Kong actually I didn't that and
it's fine to Tralee entrusting okay so
there's actually quotient from Cosman he
says that you know how was your approach
to job hunting process in how much time
I think you've already talked about you
know what was your process to each it
was for each right when linking someone
actually went you know talk to the
friend of friend and I think Edward must
have tried in the different platforms
but how much time did it take you guys
to complete this I think he'll be very
different but maybe if you can just
share a bit about how much time you took
to find the current role yeah for my
current role it was somewhat atypical I
made the decision after starting a new
contract at the Department of
Environment in the UK that's when I
wanted to transition into into AI and I
thought right I'll I'll use the career
services I had one to one coaching with
Angela McDonald which was excellent and
very helpful and she encouraged me to
update my LinkedIn settings in order to
show that I was interested and she
helped me write the sort of the goals
for her LinkedIn and the recruiter
contacted me for this role eight days
later so that was incredibly lucky I
expected it to take 12 to 18 months and
it was a lot shorter previous job
searches have been longer I think it
depends on what you're looking for and
if you're looking for something really
specific if your requirements are you
know a certain salary level and remote
work and in certain industry it'll take
you longer to find the right role but if
you're a little bit more flexible and
there's one particular thing that you
want to achieve out of your next role
you might find an opportunity comes your
way are you working expecting great
maybe you want to talk about I think you
had very you know you were able to find
a job in really quick time I think just
a month because you know I want to
travel the world you know work freely
from anywhere so that's why I was
looking for removed jobs so that's why I
took around 30 days to find a job but if
only my needs one specific I would have
a job in 10 or 15 days may be great but
I think months is still it's a very
short considering especially in digital
much in a lot of competition what about
you Celeste
yeah thanks what about you Celeste now
else you are how much time did you take
to find the current role yeah so for me
since it was a transition within my same
company based on on moving teams the
time period is two months because I had
to go through a trial period of two
months before I was approved to become a
junior product man
and then jr. for about six months before
I was group to become a full product
manager so two months of proving two
months so basically every day is an
interview oh that was those a lot but I
did hopefully prove myself enough to to
get across the threshold okay thanks
thanks so much yeah cool so I think yeah
I think to each person the journeys were
different but yeah I think the idea is
just be persistent about it and just
keep pushing yourself and although the
you won't see the result immediately but
there definitely be result of the words
all right okay so there's one question
mega which I think make gen has already
answered to the question by make de
about you know how to begin
so for it is one question for prashanta
okay so pressure on I think from
collectively I can think on their behalf
that if refresher the chances to be
first thing is we should you utilize the
services which are there begin you know
focusing on the networking in the
community outside the community if you
are into machine learning industry work
on a github profile there another
another platform that you can utilize
I think Idol is one of them you know one
of those platforms where you can
showcase some of your stuff it's morphin
the it offense but yeah i mean so the
idea is if you use more platform like
this to maximize you know to showcase
your projects that's the best way of
going about it
and definitely taking those reviews will
help you actually do at least land up
the interview and then it's you know
probably it's the time for you to shine
actually on that on that you know on
that day okay ah rights to moving
forward so this one quotient I think
table J so me you've also talked about
the job search in detail so I think they
have already talked about how their
dream
I mean how Nana really helped them one
way in the other I mean in case of
seller she made a transition from her
existing role in the company that moving
to cross the croucher with Edward you
know changing from yeah
there's one of the question that people
actually want to ask you add word you
know what how difficult was it to shift
from from rolling web development now in
more of a deep learning area yeah sure
so the way to the the part that I ended
up taking was buying him being a member
of a software engineering team at an AI
company then by helping solve problems
that were more in the AI domain I ended
up in a role that sort of straddled the
data science and software engineering
domains and by helping bridge those two
teams and those two domains you sort of
become the glue and the team and that
offers all sorts of opportunities rather
than trying to go in and disregard your
prior experience and say that's what I
used to do this is what I want to be
doing find a way to try and leverage
what you've already know and what you're
you're really good at and apply that
into a new domain or to try and enhance
the capabilities of the team by
leveraging your experience and your
knowledge of the area that you want to
move into great thanks thanks a lot
all right there's one question Phyllis
by C flurry so he you know so C ferry
wants to know like Alice do you know any
person who actually transition from web
developer or an engineering background
into product area if they did if you
know any and what kind of skills that
you know one needs to learn to move into
the product area definitely thanks for
the question I'll also use this kind of
as my wrap-up because I do have to jump
off right at the hour I've got another
meeting turn two so let's see yes first
of all yes the answer is yes a lot of
people who start in engineering or
software development move into product
and it's people that are particularly
interested in user issues and user pain
points they want to understand the
customer they usually not satisfied just
being told here's what we're building
and how to build it go they want to know
why we're building it who we're building
it for those are product people and so
there is a role
TPM or technical PM that is basically
one step towards product away from
engineering so there's a kind of a
spectrum you can go from engineering TPM
there's an inbound p.m. and then there's
kind of an outbound p.m. so within this
spectrum you get further and further
away from natural coding the technical
PM is the one that's really still in the
weeds of it but it's still kind of doing
the product work of understanding who
you're serving and why you're serving
them and how to communicate that across
teams which is really the core of it so
thank you everyone who came feel free I
saw some folks asking how to connect
feel free to message me on LinkedIn feel
free to visit our careers page I saw
some people ask about Hana first you an
opportunity with with Nicks
I'm always open to to hearing from you
so with that I'm gonna have to hop off
but I'll leave these lovely folks to
wrap this up for you thank you again
yeah thanks thanks Alice for you know
for your time and thanks again for
extending the help of joining people on
LinkedIn and help them through find an
opportunity in the organization thanks
again for everything okay right so guys
so sorry I think are we just so you know
so we ended up on me almost submitted
more than usual I mean at the time that
we were scheduled for the event but yeah
I just want to highlight the stuff I
think we have already said and all the
aluminum said very highly regarded to
start networking and networking you want
to start you know what we will do
eventually is to share you know the
aluminum profile in the careers channel
then student hub so that you can network
with them also start networking with the
other students in the community once you
send a request to these you know to
these alumini please just in the thread
just write sent so that you know we know
that your send a request we also can you
know connect with them if thick is you
know they wanted to connect you this I
wanted know mu has sent and how they
have sent it so yeah just one way about
it so please start do the networking and
I want to thank you each and every one
now for this event for joining this
webinar and we will be sharing you an
email where and we like to take a
feedback from you since it's a first
event I'm sure everyone must have been
joy this must have learned a lot from it
and
you really want to you know happen if
you really want to have these kind of
events happen more and more than please
share of feedback she really love about
this program so we can do more also you
know stay active in the color channels
know about important announcement and if
you have any questions please drop an
email to career - support at the rate of
udacity.com alright so on just you know
ending this again thank you so much
Edward and Megha for giving you valuable
time in helping the students I'm sure
their journeys it's may not be similar
as it's yours but I'm sure they'll able
to pre collect but all that you said and
hoping to have a wonderful careers like
you guys are having you know it was a
wonderful session and I would like to
thank everybody for joining in here and
just like it you know one of my mind
told me it's time to give back to the
community so just reach out to me you
need any help finding the right job I
would be happy to help always thanks so
much again and guys if you have any
questions please just write in the
corrections and we take it through with
them and yeah I would sure like to say
something to them before we sign off
sure yeah thanks for taking the time to
listen to our stories and please do feel
free to get in touch with LinkedIn just
mention that you're a participant here
and I'd be great alright thanks so much
again thanks a lot guys who create they
had all right thank you so much about it